meghan markle and prince harry go all
out glam in new york city
the couple totally stunned on the red
carpet of the intrepid air and space
museum salute to freedom gala in new
york city on wednesday night that's meg
in a red v-neck carolina herrera gown
designed for her by creative director
wes gordon as part of the pre-fall 2022
collection she completed the look with
diamond earrings a set of bracelets and
matching red pumps as for harry he
sported a black tuxedo and donned his
service pins from his time in the royal
british army as well as a poppy pin on
his lapel a symbol of remembrance for
veterans and those who served in the uk
and megan she had a poppy pin on her
dress
too the love birds walked hand in hand
as they made their way into the event
where harry gave a special presentation
i'm always proud
in addition to paying homage to the men
and women who serve our country the
event honored iheart radio chairman and
ceo bob pittman and musician slash
humanitarian john bon jovi among others
and an eyewitness tells et that the two
were seated at a table with the veterans
that the duke of sussex was honoring
adding that both he and megan were
deeply engaged in conversation with the
former vets and while many people tried
to gather around them they were politely
told by staff that harry and megan were
spending their evening focusing on the
service members
according to the eyewitness megan looked
on adoringly during harry's speech where
the 37 year old credited his own 10
years of military experience for making
him quote who i am today
of course earlier this week harry called
out the press for how they handled the
couple's decision to step down as senior
members of the royal family the two
first announced their intention in
january 2020 and officially stepped away
in the spring of 2021. we know there
were very intensive talks before the
actual decision was made and by the
queen to essentially suspend their royal
titles and to allow them to quit royal
duties but i can't recall ever hearing
such personal statements until now and i
think that shows that the depth of what
has been a family crisis and the queen
stepping in to
take decisive action um over what was
going to happen with regards to the
sussex is but also making it very clear
that she understood and respected their
decision to go and start a new life a
popular phrase used to describe the move
quote makes it a combo of megan's name
and the word exit and harry well he
slammed the media's use of the term
while sitting on a panel at wired's
rewired conference
maybe people know this maybe they don't
but the term mexic
was or is a misogynistic term um and it
was created by a troll amplified by
royal correspondents and it grew and
grew and grew onto mainstream media
but it began
with a troll harry continued talking
about misinformation online and how it
can spread we learn from
a very early age that the incentives of
publishing are not necessarily aligned
with the incentives of truth the prince
who shares a two-year-old son and a
five-month-old daughter with his wife
went on to reference his mom princess
diana who died in a car accident while
being chased by members of the paparazzi
in paris in 1997.
i know the story all too well i lost my
mother to this
um this self-manufactured
rabidness and
obviously i'm determined not to lose the
mother to my children to the same thing
meanwhile megan also spoke out this week
as part of the new york times deal book
online summit and opened up about why
it's always been important to her to
stand up for what she believes in my
husband has always said with great
privilege comes great responsibility
but even before i had any sort of
privilege in my life when my life and my
lifestyle were very very different
i always just stood up for what was
right
you